bonsoir à tous et heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau c'est huit
invités voici les titres nous recevrons
omar youssef souleimane à un écrivain
syrien qui a dû quitter son pays afin
d'éviter la prison il participe demain
avant thomas la soirée des écrivains
persécutés organisée par les itinéraires
politique à la salle de la tour à
voisins le bretonneux et puis nous on
nous entendrons najat vallaud belkacem
la ministre de l'éducation présente à
l'occasion de l'événement 90 secondes de
fraternité un événement organisé par le
site vidéo en ligne youtube des
collégiens et parmi eux des trappistes
sont devenus mettant en scène le temps
d'un on débute ce site huit invités avec
la journée des écrivains persécutés qui
se déroulent le mardi 15 novembre à la
salle de la torah voisins le bretonneux
l'événement est organisé par les
itinéraires politique a pour but de
mettre en lumière six écrivains qui sont
à travers le monde persécuté pour en
parler avec nous ce soir
omar youssef souleimane bonsoir en sap
alors dites moi pourquoi avoir décidé de
participer à cet événement alors en fait
ça c'est la deuxième fois je suis à 50
ans et vélines en yvelines yvelines 2014
à graça le poète jacques fournier c'est
lui qui organise ces événements en fait
oui
pourquoi je suis là je vous dire que
c'est pour dire
pour parler à la situation de la série
pour lire mes textes pour refaire
échanges avec les gens demain dans la
soirée parce qu'il y aura des rencontres
il y aura des questions au public il y
aura la lecture avec la musique
voilà c'est un événement important pour
vous évidemment c'est très important
parce que normalement avec toute espèce
aujourd'hui avec la politique avec la
situation je vous dire mondiale buyster
aux séries ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
comme des artistes comme des écrivains
comme des poètes ou comme même comme
journaliste s'est contacté des gens être
avec avec lire d'autres textes et entre
c'est ça en fait pour moi c'est la
continuation de la révolution syrienne
qui on l'a commencée en 2011 toujours
continuer il ne finira pas comment on
les continuer parce la parole toujours
dans le combat à travers ce type de deux
événements évidemment malgré qu je suis
à l'exil et en france ça fait quatre ans
si la maison très dire quand même que
l'exil de phényle pas il reste longtemps
mais la révolution aussi ne finira pas
et dites moi quels sont les
et les retours que vous pouvez avoir
lors de ce type d'événement qu'est ce
que le public vient vous dire
normalement en fait t'es beau bal des
questions pourquoi je suis venu en
france pourquoi comment la révolution
syrienne a commencé parce que
malheureusement dans les médias seront
balle pas aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir
année un bal codes de la guerre en série
au balo d'ail hachée l'origine de
charles assalé les milices islamistes
ça c'est vrai bien sûr mais aussi on a
on avait une révolution pacifique qui a
commencé en série elle continuait
toujours pour bar des manifestations
pacifiques par des écrivains par les
artistes barre des collègues par des
écoles qui est ouvert aujourd'hui en
syrie malgré malgré qu la guerre donc il
ya toujours ces questions c'est quoi la
situation en syrie
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai qu'il
faut le dire vous êtes écrivant de base
vous avez été aussi journaliste et
durant le début de la révolution en
syrie
vous avez été ensuite traqués et
pourchassés par la police
la police de bachar el assad donc vous
êtes enfui et vous êtes arrivé en france
pourquoi ce choix de la france bat ce
qu'en fait quand j'ai fouillé de la
série
de ce régime dictateur je suis allé en
jordanie à amman
alors j'avais plusieurs choix soit en
france en allemagne aux états unis mais
en fait j'ai choisi la france car déjà
en fait j'adore la littérature française
quand j'étais adolescent je lis aragon
et paul eluard suis tombé amoureux par
rapport leur poésie qui m'accompagne
plusieurs années de ma vie
et aussi parce que la france comme je
suis réfugié politique en france
la france protège les réfugiés voilà et
la basse est française à mende
m'accueillait facilement c'était facile
pour moi de venir en france
vous faites souvent ce type d'événement
comme ça à des vers les gens pour leur
raconter votre histoire
oui en fait je fais ça va mal en france
et malheureusement si j'ai une chance là
parce que j'ai appris la langue
française bien sûr au début c'est très
difficile parce que je connaissais pas
cette langue mais dès que j'ai appris
cette langue dès que j'ai imprimé les
l'ag de livres aux français en arabe
c'est le dernier livre qui est sorti qui
s'appelle et loire de damas qui est
sortie de l'édition le temps des cerises
et en raison aux grâces de l'écrire
grâce de la poésie grâce de dd ami qui
veut les rencontres en france où il joue
juin prochain à paris dans le civil
s'étaient ajoutés dans le festival
d'avignon cette année vous raconter
l'histoire et en même temps on fait pour
dire qu est-ce qu parce que j'ai pas mal
de contacts avec des syriens à
l'intérieur et extérieur pour beaucoup
voudraient dire adresser leurs opinions
et qu'est ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils
veulent exactement pour la société
française parce que c'est très important
pour nous pour vous laisser rien quand
même à l'intérieur malgré qu aujourd'hui
c'est paco bien sûr le sait en série a
mais en même temps ils sont suisses aux
billes est devenu une partie de moi
voilà et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cet événement de cette idée de monsieur
fournier à l'initiative de ça je trouve
que c'est une idée très très importante
parce que normalement demain il y aura
un journaliste et romancier afghans et à
romans romancier turc tout cette quête
on est roi il y aura aussi une
journaliste française qui a un qui va
organiser la soirée
il ya aussi une chanteuse syrienne c'est
normal donc je trouve que c'est très
riche parce qu'on a la même situation
tous les trois ou délicate vous dire
mais on est de plusieurs cultures ou
plusieurs civilisations comme rencontre
là en france
bon moi cet échange entre nous mêmes et
entre nous et le public
je trouve que c'est extraordinaire c'est
un combat qu'il faut continuer ce en
fait ce blocage qui a par rapport aux
écrivains dans certains pays il faut
toujours alerté et le pur vie en fait
bien sûr normalement ça finira bas
jusqu'à la fin de la vie il faut
continuer toujours comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est ça c'est vraiment pour moi
c'est la résistance par ben barka la
body bien sûr pour qu'est ce qu'on dit
des rencontres même le travail comme un
journaliste au comme quand j'écris un
livre des résulats le dernier livre
qu'ils veulent et crise appelle le petit
terroristes j'ai défini est à moi
toujours rien décidé de le sortir de
beaux douleur dans le monde arabe
parce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui on donne le
monde arabe malheureusement vie au moyen
âge on est dans une situation très très
durs comme comme on a vécu en europe il
ya des siècles et des siècles
car en tuer les gens en raison de
leur religion alors idc c'est horrible
il faut toujours combat il faut toujours
continuer cette récente n'importe où et
n'importe qu'est-ce qu'on fait chacun
dans son coin où chacun de son travail
quand même eh bien ce sera le mot de la
fin
toujours combattre c'est ça le message
bien sûr je remercie omar youssef
souleimane on passe en autres sujets
youtube le site d'hébergement de vidéos
lancé jeudi dernier le concours toi même
tu filmes 148 140 films ont été réalisés
dans toute la france dont 2 réalisé par
deux jeunes trappistes lors de l'annoncé
des résultats sur place nous nous y
étions et on a on en a profité pour
poser quelques questions à la ministre
de l'éducation
najat vallaud belkacem
nous sommes au siège de google france à
paris où est organisé la remise de prix
dépend du projet toi même tu filmes donc
tu as locaux de google passe en
compagnie de la ministre najat vallaud
belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous avez remis un prix
jeunesse si je ne me trompe pas est ce
que vous nous en dire plus pourquoi ce
prix et pourquoi cette équipe qui vient
de mantes la jolie en plus vont d'abord
toi même tu filmes c'est un projet
absolument extraordinaire parce que
initiée par youtube qui lui donne sa
puissance de frappe en faisant connaître
plus large public donc les vidéo
réalisée et produite par des jeunes un
peu partout sur le territoire
il a fallu un vrai tour de france pour
tout les trouver ces vidéos autour de
quoi autour de la fraternité
or moi je trouve que on est vraiment
dans une période où on a besoin
d'entendre parler de fraternité et que
nul autre que les jeunes savent le faire
aussi bien qu ils ont fait ce soir avec
leur coeur avec leurs tripes ils ont
réussi à nous faire passer des messages
très simple sur ce que c'est que la
fraternité qui est plus court que la
solidarité la fraternité c'est ce qui
nous relie les uns et les autres parce
qu'on est tous des humains et qu'on
arrive à voir dans les autres d'autres
soi même en quelque sorte et c'est pour
cette raison que on a envie que les
autres aussi et de l'égalité et de la
liberté donc dans la devise républicaine
liberté égalité fraternité je trouve que
c'est quasiment la fraternité qui est la
plus importante parce que ensuite elle
permet des deux autres et donc les
jeunes en gros ils nous ont montré tout
ça avec leur image leur mot avec un
talent inouï beaucoup d'esthétique de
beauté dans ce qu'ils ont réalisé et moi
je suis très contente qu'on puisse les
mettre en valeur comme ça c'est pour ça
que je tenais à être là ce soir juste
pour leur rendre hommage en fait et ce
prix justement pourquoi pourquoi ce film
là qu'est ce qui vous a touché
particulièrement parce que les jeunes
qui ont réalisé ce film là donc les clés
c'est comme ça qu'ils s'appellent ont
bien jouer avec les codes du suspense
de la peur même un moment donné parce
que le film commence sur une scène où on
voit un homme ivre mort qui essaye
d'ouvrir sa voiture et qui semble être
attaqué par deux jeunes
c'est ce qu'on croit en tout cas est en
fait à la fin du film on comprend qu'ils
n'ont pas du tout à attaquer les jeunes
ils lui ont bien pris ses clés mais en
réalité ils ont installé à l'arrière de
la voiture pour conduire à sa place pour
lui éviter un accident parce qu'il était
ivre et donc ils l'ont bien raccompagné
chez lui et je trouve que cette chute
qui est tellement en décalage avec la
crainte qu'on pouvait avoir au début du
film passe est très fort très très fort
et puis évidemment ça va contre tous les
préjugés les stéréotypes qu'on peut se
faire des jeunes de banlieues forcément
s'ils sont là c'est pour attaquer
d'emploi sont là pour aider
ça fait du bien alors on sent que c'est
un projet qui vous a vraiment touché ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer ce type de
projets menés à l'échelle des écoles des
lycées est ce que vous ça vous plairait
de mettre ça en place peut-être sur le
principe d'amener les élèves à
construire ensemble un projet qui peut
être la réalisation d'un film
en fait on fait de plus en plus dans nos
établissements scolaires c'est
d'ailleurs si vous regardez bien en quoi
consiste la réforme du collège
elle consiste notamment à donner une
grande part cette construction de
projets par les élèves eux-mêmes
on introduit de plus en plus d'art et de
culture dans les écoles donc évidemment
tout ce qui est musique clips
réalisation de films c'est des choses
qui vont se pratique est de plus en plus
le numérique également le numérique
aussi absolument l'utilisation parce que
pour pouvoir filmer leur iphone donc
l'utilisation des houthis se développent
et sa points de mieux en mieux à l'école
après moi je tiens quand même à dire
j'ai beau être mises de l'éducation
nationale je ne considère pas que ce
soit à l'école de tout faire ce qui
était beau ce soir c'est de mettre en
lumière des structures que je connais
bien pour avoir été élu local et m'être
occupé d'elle c'est les mjc c'est toutes
les structures de l'éducation populaire
qui font un boulot magnifique il faut
pas qu'on essaie de le faire à leur
place
et là en l'occurrence ce sont ces
structures là qui ont accompagné les
jeunes et je trouve que le fait que
youtube met en lumière ce que font ces
petites structures de quartier ben c'est
ça qui est beau c'est aussi ça la
fraternité c'est quand les plus
puissants s'allier à des moins puissants
et qu' il donne à voir ce qu'on est
capables de faire ensemble
c'est la fin de ce sept huit invités
merci de l'avoir subie on se retrouve
demain